[Music]
socking a hey Mt do you like Pokemon uh
yeah okay then no [__] huh yeah that's
that's actually shocker we're really
peeling back the layers here do you like
do you like do you like trains it
depends I I got a better question you
like something mechanical what's your
favorite mechanical thing mechanical
pencil see I there's always something a
good one though that's a different one
is it cuz you like the way the Eraser
feels when you click it oh what's the
best brand of mechanical pencil uh oh
man I don't know any Brands uh I know
what they look like but you know it's
hard for me to and I could arrange it by
color and Order big big do make good
ones you know what I do it's funny
you're going to love this I put the
thing out and I hold it down and I
pretend I'm injecting myself with it
it's really funny
it's we all did that hack bit as all of
us all of us every single [__] kid
growing up did that pit oh [__] okay
mint here's other question are you good
with numbers uh it depends which ones
the zero through nine kind I'm okay with
well they're all zero through nine when
you think about it
right yeah I mean every number one of
the other numbers one of those numbers
10 through 19 so you're not like a base
11 kind of gy no [__] no letters in
your
[__]
too okay anyway uh this is a this
is no that oh real quick the question I
was going to ask her what was your first
Pokemon Generation oh yeah uh Gen
4 which was because I didn't play past
[__] silver and gold uh system was DS
it because my brother had a copy of
Pearl and I was like oh my goodness I
want to play Pokemons and then he gave
me diamond and then that was my first
game f generation their hand started
with touch screens this [__] makes me
sick it's unbelievable bro I had the old
game boy that had like this shitty like
scen yeah it ter or and I had a I I had
I had a Game Gear that needed six
batteries every one hour to [__] play
Sonic on it it was a nightmare I
remember when all I remember when all
these youngans got uh remember when they
all got hustled out of those [__] uh
what system did they bring back the
Super Nintendo or whatever it was
temporarily when they brought back
something as a retro thing and they all
went out and bought it and I'm like yo
bro we've been emulating that [__] for
years have emulators I have a laptop and
a controller why would I go out and buy
a console like an old console I had seen
that uh so yeah yeah go ahead when we
traded our [__] Pokemon mint we had
to pay $25 for a [__] Link cable we
had a you know how good we had to
connect our things with a cord and then
the Pokemon had to travel the length of
cord into the other game boy for you to
then have it and then there was also
this thing called the the World Trade
Center
oh it was [__] crazy it was a
beautiful pair of buildings I never got
to see them buildings those was 10
months old yeah when 911 happened oh and
we also used to have these things called
malls right and we I've been to malls we
would go you've been you've been to a
husk of a mall yeah yeah exactly true we
would go to these malls right and all
like they like Santa would be there and
it'd be like a $30,000 Christmas display
oh yeah and it would be like all crazy
and nowadays you probably just see a lot
of Puerto Rican kids riding around on
those fake Power Wheels yeah it's it's
like now it's like people get people
getting a trim up next to the JC Penny
yeah we a lot of shuttered stores it's
like when we went to the Coliseum there
was Gladiators fighting in it now you go
to the Coliseum now and it looks like
that that's what it was it was [__]
crazy yeah we used to have Santa and
Italian ice stands and now you just have
Indians selling phone cases and black
people yeah no that's pretty much what a
mall is but anyway the story is a
Pokemon story which by the way includes
all the things you mentioned oh
nice lap LAPD off officer ignores backup
call to play Pokémon go as you
do okay but what was what was the
Pokemon do we
know 2017
2017 also what was the call my phone
thought you were talking to it and it
just told me what Pokemon was oh sorry
no that's hilarious uh
but no I'm just curious like is if it's
a rare one how do you blame him yeah I
don't know like what a rare one is in
Pokemon go I I think at this point in
Pokemon go they only had the first gen
they were adding like gen to another
stuff so I think it must have been like
like a new one or something maybe they
were just adding like second generation
stuff at this point wait so what I'm
wondering is is he driving around with
his phone open looking at Pokemon yeah
he's probably trying to he's probably
driving around in a square because it's
probably in that general area and he's
probably trying to play Pokemon while
he's driving as light
changes this pesky guy yeah this
actually makes me really mad that a cop
in [__] La would do this when he has
a job to do he has a job to do of
driving around picking up criminals and
then releasing them with no bail you
know shouldn't he be doing his job of
not enforcing the law uh yeah well no
also that and also shooting people's
dogs yeah he should be out there
standing shooting people's dogs standing
in front of a Walgreens letting people
steal $999 worth of stuff nice to have
more balls and have the
potion it's the video the LAPD took
years to release this patrol
car they've been trying to get this
video since
2017 and that's how long they'll [__]
around with your Freedom of Information
Act 2023 now we got it 2017 is 2023
that's how long nice to
[Music]
and it's the video the LAPD took years
to release this patrol car recording of
two officers playing the online game
Pokemon go instead of responding to a
call about a robbery in
progress you know what didn't take years
to release um all of my Pokemon reviews
all my Pokémon movie reviews those are
all out and all of them I've reviewed
all of the Pokémon movies and this th
that took less time than getting this
video Yeah well yeah and by the way very
good at plugging her videos she does
really good at it you're Pro I don't
know where you I just went to the
[__] uh who was the one that was used
to be really good at it they used to
sliping the Jericho the Chris jerich you
went to the Chris Jericho School of
plugs really good cuz he used to he was
the best at doing a quick live read in
the middle of a story and it was over
before you even realized it Chris
Jericho she's so diat TOA of rock and
rolla yeah Y2J Y2J no no Millennial
countdown clock he had a list he had
a he had a he had the fountain hair
silver shirt that everybody had in high
school thousand moves nobody had that in
high school when I was in high school
Lion Salt thousand thousand moves that's
what that's what we wore in high school
instead of like f and [__] like fan
of the Calgary Stampede beat up Goldberg
in real life come on Chris
Jericho what people wore in my high
school were fur
tails and blue hair look it's s it's not
the butt plug ones cuz that's fine I
worry about that I don't know that's
kind of I've seen chicks do that
sometimes I've seen guys do that too
MCH but I've seen some chicks do it
where it's kind of hot sometimes you're
like that's kind of hot but don't leave
it in too long ladies he's
Ina back up on the recording you hear
the officers minutes after driving away
discussing how to catch the Pokemon
character Snorlax it was a Snorlax y it
was a Snorlax you know what can I say
something I'm glad that we got real
journalism here they got the qu they
never get the questions answered that we
want to know the answers to but they
finally got us the like the details to
the story usually they end a story and
we never like well which Pokemon was it
it was a SN this is one of the only
times they actually Snorlax by the way
was it the one with a cowboy hat was it
a cuz if it's a rare one like a Snorlax
with a cowboy hat like I get why they
[__] stopped who cares we can agree
right Snorlax is like probably I mean I
don't know a lot about Pokemon but if I
had to guess I would assume it's
probably the most one of the most
marketed ones besides pikach a lot of
people yeah well hold on she would know
yes what's the most marketed besides
Pikachu so I what I've seen is it's uh
Pikachu then like Snorlax and Eevee oh
Eevee eeve and then whatever new
starters that they have at the moment
okay yeah I was going to say cuz that
look that's something right there where
I go oh my God we're going to make a
[__] billion dollars off this big
stupid thing like they probably made a
billion dollars in just [__] plushies
of this thing they probably make a bean
bag chair out of a Snorlax D that would
make an actually guarantee you I
guarantee you I know for a fact they
used to have one I guarantee you that
that's a thing cuz if they didn't Market
yeah there it is on the John in chat
said Snorlax is [__] goated yeah he
is he really is he's one of the top tier
uh you can get you can get yourself a be
a be it'll cost you a couple hundred
bucks but you can definitely get one o
yeah on character Snorlax ignoring the
robbery call even though according to
court documents there was already a
Snorlax there ironically he could have
got it at the robbery call so what who
cares it's La we'll catch the next
robbery there's going to be like 50
today there's going to be more robberies
and Snorlax to give the guy a
break he knows where his priorities are
they were only 200 yard away from the
store he catches everything yeah but
that that would have been outside the
gym and then you can't catch the Snorlax
these people don't even understand how
to play Pokemon that's probably what
bothers me about this the most it's two
football fields away that's too far it's
too far yeah that's like when that's
like when my mom used to tell me to
pause the game or something and I got to
go and like this is live there's no you
can't do nothing about that mhm 420 Noob
Noob poner is going to kill me if I
[__] leave are you [__] kidding me
13-year-old kid called me a [__] okay
you want me to walk what am I supposed
to do with that everything I don't TCH
everything and now I need to kill him
and then I need to keep tapping this
button so that I'm teabagging him you
don't know how this is ma you don't know
how this works mom he was making fun of
you I was defending your honor I can't
go eat dinner right now it's the things
he said about you I remember dud teabag
remember when that came out that was one
of my favorite when that first started
coming out it was my favorite thing to
do when you shot somebody in a game and
then you just went up and down crouched
I know teabag teag oh they're still
doing that're still teag
teag any any ball or fart stuff is will
will will always last I I even laugh
when I'm on the receiving end and it's
just some stranger teabagging me and
being like you suck I'm like all it's
pretty funny I do
suck but you're still pretty high up
there for not catching so these cops
just keep talking about Pokemon huh the
officers were fired but sued to get
reinstated their case going all the way
to a California appeals court the
officers are imagine how much money was
son he's two idiots their patrol car
recordings should be dismissed because
they were private
conversations no they were on the job
it's the same thing as if you had a
conversation at Amazon and they're
filmed you instead of working you can't
go it was a private conversation no no
no you're on the job yeah I I can't be
like I can't be on camera working as a
cop just turn to my partner and be like
I [__] hate ends and you're like dude
dude body camera and you're like oh [__]
and he's going to turn to his black
partner and say that which is made it
really weird look at his partner they
probably won't expectation of privacy
when you're on the job when you're a
public worker but the appeals court
disagreed and sided with the police
board which ruled the officers committed
misconduct that was unprofessional and
embarrassing and violated the trust of
the public yeah but I don't think it
violated the trust of the public I mean
not just them two differes did it I
think I think what they did is on par
with about the level of expectation I
have from the LAPD yeah but now they're
just going to work you know guarantee
you guarantee you they already have a
job at another like [__] another
County away at like a local sheriff's or
coffee City or some [__] pick them up
yeah they're going to be out there in
Santa Clarita County and good luck
catching any good Pokemon out there it's
all Rural and I thought Pokemon go was
kind of based on population so good luck
fellas all they have out there is geod
dudes who the [__] wants a geod dude
catching a Snorlax try that in a small
town get it oh I like that
heyy yeah yeah yeah
yeah those Rich gym owners north of
Richmond take that P what are we
fighting take that commies I've never
heard of that song before it's not great
I won't okay I wouldn't listen to it if
I ref oh you don't like the guy that
looks like Santino and plays the guitar
I don't know who Santino is was back in
2017 but the video just came to light
thanks to a public records request Derek
Dennis
ABC News Derek Dennis I'm holding in a
fart